So what is this user
preferred text size anyway?
Well, for
accessibility purposes Android allows
users to customize their font size.
Users that have trouble reading
text can increase their font size.
You can normally find this option in
the display settings on your phone or
tablet under font size.
It's often also available through
the accessibility settings.
With scale-independent pixels,
16 sp is exactly the same as
16 dp when the user's font
size is normal or 100%.
But when the user's font size is large,
for example 125%,
16 sp will translate to 20 dp or
1.25 times 16.
Using sp units will make for
a better experience for
people with impaired eyesight.
You'll be saving someone the frustration
of downloading your awesome app,
only to find that they
can't read the text.